ايه شو الاوكراني فلودي ميرزلنسكي قال من
جانبه ان اوكرانيا بحاجه الى صواريخ بعيده
المدى من اجل ازاله خطر مسماه الارهاب
الروسي واضاف زنسكي في خطاب له ان بلاده
ستنذله كل ما في وسطها لتاكد من ان
شركائها يفتحون هذا الامداد الحيوي موضوع
بسيط
اذا تمكنا من توفير قوات صاروخيه كافيه
لجيشنا اوكرانيا بحاجه الى صواريخ بعيده
المدى من اجل ازاله هذا الخطر من المحتل
الذي وضعها قادفات صواريخه في مكان ماء
بعيدا عن خط المواجهه ويدمر بها المدن
الاوكرانيه شكرا للجميع في العالم الذين
يسرون معنا على انه لا يمكن ان يكون هناك
اي من المحرمات في توريد الاسلحه للحمايه
من الارهاب الروسيه سنفعل كل ما في وسعنا
لتاكد من ان الشركاء يفتحون هذا الامداد
الحيويه على وجه الخصوص منظومات اي تي اي
سي ام اس والاسلحه المماثله